Finally we need to make some assumptions in order to use one way Anova. The
first in normality. All the populations from which the samples are from are
normally distributed. Another is homogeneity of variance. The data come from
populations that have equal amounts of variability and finally independence of
observations. The results found from one sample won't affect the others.
However, we can violate these assumptions under certain conditions. We can
violate the normality assumption if the sample size is large. We can violate
the homogeneity of variance assumption. If all the samples have nearly equal
sample sizes, and the ratio of any two variances does not exceed 4. We have to
maintain independence of observations but we can use randon assignment to
conditions to help up meet this assumption. Let's do a quick summary of ANOVA
to wrap up this lesson. I'm not actually going to rap this time though, we're
just going to wrap up the lesson. If we have three or more samples and we want
to know if any two of them are significantly different, we look at both the
between group variability, and the within group variability. Between group
variability is a measure of how spaced apart these sample means are from each
other. And we do that by finding the grand mean and each squared deviation from
the grand mean for each sample mean. We multiply each sample size by the
squared deviation of each sample mean from the grand mean. Then we add them up.
Then we have to look at the within group variability which is essentially the
square deviation of each value in each sample from the respective sample mean.
So we add up all sums of squares from their respective sample mean and then we
have to find the average sum of squares for each by dividing by the degrees of
freedom. In the case of the between groups, this is the number of samples minus
1, and for within groups this is the total number of values minus the number of
groups. This is the same as adding the degrees of freedom for each group. There
we have our F statistic. And if it falls out here in the critical region, past
the F critical value, we'll reject the null. After making a statistical
decision, we can use the multiple comparison test, one of which is Tukey's
Honestly Significant Difference. Which is a value that if any two sample means
have a difference greater than that value, they're considered honestly
significantly different. You've also learned how to determine what proportion
of the difference between mean is due the independent variable. You've also
learned how to determine what proportion of the difference between means is due
the independent variable. That's theta squared and that's a wrap.